الكرام الى فقره وقفه مع الحدث التي
نتناول فيها قرار القناه الجزيره رفعه
قضيه الصحفيه الفلسطينيه شيرين ابو عاقله
الى المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه واقفه مع
الحدث اليوم مع الزميل عبد الله العالي
اهلا وسهلا اهلا بك عبد الله
نتوقف معك اذا عند هذه القضيه قضيه صحفيه
ورفع هذه القضيه من قبل الجزيره الى
المحكمه
الذي اصدرته على موقع رسمي تفيد بانه خلال
السته اشهر التي تفصلنا عن مقتل شيرين ابو
عقله كان هناك فريق قانوني تابع للجزيره
على حقيقي في هذه القضيه لانه من اجل ذلك
همم قام همم
الكثيري من همم الشهادات من شهودهن من
شهودنا الحياه وانه بالاضافه الى ذلك فحصل
بالشكل ده فحص بشكل دقيق المقاط مقاطع
الفيديو التي سجلت ووثقت لحظه اغتيال
شيرين ابو عقله والامر الثاني الثالث ايضا
هو انه جمع ادله جنائيه ايضا وقام بفحصها
فيما يتعلق بهذه الجريمه وانه انطلاقا من
كل ذلك جمع ادله جديده
خلص من خلالها الى ان ما حدث لم يكن فقط
عمليه قتل يرتكبها الجيش الاسرائيلي
ولكنها كانت عمليه قتل عمد بمعنى ان
نيه القتل اللي كانت موجوده وفقا لبيان
الجزيره لدى الجنود الاسرائيليين الذين
اطلقوا النار عليها وبالتالي رفعت الجزيره
هذه القضيه امام المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
اليوم من اجل دفع المحكمه الى بدء تحقيقه
يفضي الى تحديد الاشخاص الذين اطلقوا
النار والاشخاص الذين امروهم بذلك ومن ثم
محاكمه محاكمه هؤلاء واليك وبالتالي عدم
اغلاه عقابي المسؤولين عن هذه الجريمه عدم
افلاتهم من العقاب هذا هو الهدف النهائي
بالنسبه للاجراءات التي بدات اليوم من قبل
الجزيره التي تقول بانها ستظل متمسكه
ومتشبهه بضروره مسائله ومحاسبه اولئك
الذين قتالوا هذه الصحفيه
من هذه القضيه
قامت بها مؤسسات الاعلاميه بينها الجزيره
ولكن هناك تحقيقات قامت بها وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه منها الاسيو سياده
ومنها كذلك
الى ان مصدر اطلاق النار كان من الجهه
الاسرائيلي
وبالتالي حملت الجيش الاسرائيليه مسؤوليه
قتل هذه الصحفيه بشكل واضح وجليل لكن ما
هو همم اكثر ربما همم اهميه من ذلك هو
تحقيق مشترك اثرته مؤسسه فلسطينيه
ومؤسسه اسرائيليه ايضا اسرائيليه بريطانيا
لان مؤسسها اسرائيلي لكن مقرها يوجد في
لندن
وافاد هذا التحقيق همم بتفنيد الخلاصات
الاسرائيليه التي تقول بانه ربما كان
اطلاق النار جاء من مصدر اسرائيلي لكنه لم
يكن مقصوده فندت تلك الروايه وقالت بان
همم شيرين ابو عقله اترك اطلقت عليها
النيران من همم سياره وصفحه اسرائيليه
كانت ضمن خمس سيارات مصفحه اسرائيليه توجد
على بعد 200 متر من المكان الذي كان يوجد
فيه الفريق الصحفي الذي يضم شيرين ابو
عقله همم وهناك ايضا تطورا مهم حدث الشهر
الماضي وهو اعلان الولايات الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وانت تعرفين ان تشرين
ابو عقله تحمل الجنسيه الامريكيه وكانت
الولايات المتحده وقد تماطلت ونورت كثيره
لانها اولا لم تتمنى الموقف القائد بعمديه
القتل او القصيده لانها ايضا حاولت ان
يكون التحقيق تحقيق مشتركا بين
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين لكن الضغط الذي
مرسي على الاداره الامريكيه من قبل 57
برلمانيا امريكيا الديمقراطيا دفع لاداره
الامريكيه في منتصف الشهر الماضي الى ان
تبدا تحقيقا سيجريه مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالامريكي بشان هذه القضيه وهو
التطور اللافت همم جعل الضغط اكبر على
السلطات الاسرائيليه وهدفه ايضا هو همم
القاء الضوئي بشكل كامل على ظروف التي
ارتكبت في هذه الجريمه همم دون ان تكون له
بالضروره تداعيات قضائيه رغم ان مكتبه
تحقيقات الفتراليه يتبع لوزاره العداله
وزاره العداله الامريكي
بالنسبه الاسرائيليين يتراوح الموقف بين
القول اولا بان الاسرائيليين لم يكونوا
مسؤولين عن مقتل الصحفي وان الصحفيه قتلت
لانها اصيبت بنيران
فلسطيني وقالت بانه حينما كانت حينما حدث
ذلك كان هنالك تبادل الاطلاق النار بين
الجنود الاسرائيليين
ومسلحين فلسطينيين وان النيران التي قد
قتلت شيرين ابو عقله كانت نيرانا في
فلسطينيه لكن الاسرائيلين عدلوا لاحقا عن
هذه الروايه وغيره بشكل كبير اذا انهم همم
في منتصفه في سبتمبر ايلو للماضي قالوا
بان شيرين ابو عقله توفيت على الارجح نظرا
لاصابتها بصاص وطلق من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيلي لكن ذلك لم يكن امرا مقصوده
لكن من الواضح ان الاداره الاسرائيليه لا
تريد اطلاقا تحقيقا يفضي الى تحديد
الاشخاص المسؤولين عن اطلاق النار ولا
اولئك الذين امروا به وانها لا تريد ابدا
محاكمتهم او مسائلهم والدليل على ذلك انها
رفضت بشكل قاطع
وادامت اولا قرار الولايات المتحده ببدا
تحقيق في هذه القضيه من قبل مكتب
التحقيقات الفيدرالي ورفضت اي تعاونين معه
وقالت بانها لن تسمح ابدا للامريكيين
باستنطاق جنود او ضباط اسرائيليين وهذا
الدليل على ان اسرائيل حتى وان كانت تقر
ضمنيا بمسؤوليه جيشها عن هذه الجريمه الا
انها ترفض ايام
او محاكمه للمتورطين فيه بشكل مباشر ان
كانوا اسرائيليين فعلا
شكرا لك